it's been more than five years since  marvel vs capcom 3 so we're probably due  for a new one right i'm tony and this  gamespot news update is gonna be a real  fight polygon reports that marvel vs  capcom for is in the works and that it  will be officially revealed at  playstation experienced this weekend  it's not clear if this announcement  indicates any exclusivity for the game  especially since marvel vs capcom 3 was  on both ps3 and xbox 360 what is being  rumored is that will see a focus on the  Marvel Cinematic Universe when it comes  to the game's roster some more heroes  like ant-man and Groot less x-men like  Cyclops and Wolverine the reports say  marvel vs capcom for is slated for  release in 2017 we'll have to see what  happens at PSX but six years is plenty  of time to wait for a fighting game  sequel stay tuned to gamespot for more  and for all the latest on Marvel and  Capcom games you're already in the right  place  you